[Music]
listen i don't want to make this about
me but you and i i feel like we got the
bright colors going on did we understand
the assignment i feel like we
telepathically knew what to do we did it
assignment understood oh no i'm not a
superhero
i'm the host of the junos you're a
marvel superhero right we know harry
styles has entered the mcu as arrows
what a pleasure to make your
acquaintance shawn mendes is here
tonight from one musician to another can
you get him in the mcu i mean he's
already my superhero
but but he should be the world superhero
as well
shall we put that in a sound bite and
send it out to the world shawn mendes
should be a superhero as for
qualifications jp sax has us covered
shawn mendes is here tonight how would
you describe him in one word
perfect
oh we'd have to agree and while simu
scouts some canadian talent for marvel
he's also dishing on his new movie i do
want to know how you reacted the first
time you saw margot robbie as barbie and
ryan gosling as ken like what was your
reaction oh my god i remember
getting to the screen test a few days
before we were going to camera for the
first time and seeing them standing
together just being like oh wow and
right on cue our punk rock barbie and
ken walk in congratulations uh i see
that shiny ring can i see the race
it looks beautiful you searched well you
got engaged in paris the engagement
party was paris themed are we having a
wedding in france maybe maybe baby baby
[Music]
everybody i've interviewed is so excited
that you're here tonight so much of my
childhood was like rocking out to
skaterboy
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm with you is my favorite one the
balance
[Applause]
and you get to see how much canada is
obsessed with her right oh it's been
crazy every night it's wild we're
obsessed with canada and the carpet was
filled with more canadian talent for the
juno awards my name is
and i
am
canadian
your air guitar skills right now are so
impressive
ut canada is very lucky to have you all
right i'm sorry i did not pay him to say
that i swear
and what about all this money
oh that was way too quick put that away
put that away
i am definitely shaking
i'm gonna like hold on to your hands
give your support right now
awesome i'm just so excited that they're
here my whole family's here okay guys
this is the first time i'm getting in
the middle of a group because i want to
be a part of all of this yes and while
morgan becomes the beach's newest member
some golden trophies were handed out
dabbing to juno sean receives the
international achievement award and fan
choice and a big night for deborah cox
who made history please join me
in welcoming deborah cox to the canadian
music hall of fame
becoming the first black woman to be
inducted deborah performs a medley of
her hits on the juno stage there was a
lot of emotions i was holding back a lot
of tears just to be on stage singing in
front of the audience and singing songs
that uh the song that started it all
where we go from here and ending with
you know my mantra
really felt beautiful but taking home
the biggest accolade was montreal
charlotte cardin who took home four
junos including artist single and album
of the gear and yes
that hardware is pretty heavy
we just did a photo with the four of
them and like one of my fingers was like
stuck between two of the trophies and
like i think i might lose my finger